let's talk about the biggest comeback in
sports history after the corona virus
pandemic canceled months of games
tournaments and races athletes are
starting to compete again
major sports had to come back being away
was getting expensive
billions and billions of dollars will be
lost by sports organizations so was it
all worth the risk
how have athletes been affected what
about the fans and will sports ever be
the same again
[Music]
the Great Depression two world wars
hurricanes and wildfires they've all to
some extent derailed the big sports but
nothing like this pandemic the NBA will
be out of action until further notice
major events have been canceled or
postponed for the first time in many
years right now every school is just
thinking are we gonna get through this
damage limitation putting an actual
number on the financial hit is hard but
we're talking billions it's an industry
that affects so many others and on a
global scale not just in lost team
revenue but for the stadiums and arenas
a TV rights tourism travel retail
services betting and all the rest of it
now if we just look at u.s. stadiums
alone and the salaries of the people who
work there people like the hotdog
sellers t-shirt vendors cleaners and
security staff the pandemic is expected
to wipe out about 370 million dollars in
people's wages so the urge for sports to
come back is strong but let's not forget
why they were banned in the first place
[Music]
remember how bad things got in Italy for
a while there the town of Bergamo was
one of the hardest hit places in Europe
they traced the spread of the virus to a
football match in Milan in February
between bergama's team Atlanta and
Valencia a team from Spain that day tens
of thousands of fans traveled on buses
and trains to the match where they
hugged and celebrated one doctor called
it a biological bomb social distancing
has to be applied everyone in the world
then a sporting event is exactly the
opposite of that and in the early days a
lot of people just didn't take it
seriously this is Rudy Gobert of the
Utah Jazz goofing around with reporters
microphones a few days later he tested
positive and not long after that the
NBA's shut down so there were plenty of
reasons for suspending play nobody
wanted to risk spreading the virus to
players spectators and will everyone
else and we've seen a number of elite
athletes writing about their experience
suffering from a covered nineteen and
expanded consequences once recovered
from the symptoms when they start to
train again severe fatigue and inability
to cope with a specific training load so
that meant hitting pause but if you're
an athlete it's not that simple
athletes only get a limited number of
years at the top of their game Tiger
Woods needs four more majors to break
the record for the most titles Serena
Williams is 38 but she's still two shy
of breaking Margaret courts record for
the same
title many of these guys who are at the
peak of their physical condition and
they may not be at their peak one year
from now or two years from now now think
about the Olympics for a second
athletes trained for four years so they
peak in time for the games that's 15,000
of them at the 2020 Olympics and
Paralympics and Tokyo have been
postponed for at least a year that
four-year cycle it's designed that you
pick at the right time it's like a
finely tuned machine it is super super
difficult to maintain that elite level
of fitness and conditioning outside of
an elite Academy the athletes have had
to get creative
[Music]
I just had to adapt by buying equipment
to basically train at home
pretty much all athletes across the
world who have been in isolation for
this whole lot I would need at least two
to three months to get anywhere near
back to the condition that they have
before there are lots of unknowns well
the Olympics even go ahead and who's
going to cover the losses the
International Olympic Committee is
offered to chip in with 800 million
dollars but some estimates suggest it
could cost Japan as much as six billion
Olympians lose out to they lose out on
the biggest stage they'll ever be on
maybe one percent of all the athletes
will manage to get some endorsements
that are enough where they can focus on
the training and still live a decent
life basically sitting on the bench
costs money a lot of it it's why the
major sports are risking a comeback
I'd like to think that people were
rushing back sport because they're ever
so desperate to make sure the fans have
got something and they want to look
after all the people involved in sport
that's not the reason it's the business
contracts contracts with broadcasters
are the biggest source of revenue for
almost all major sports the English
Premier League have agreed to a
three-year contract with broadcasters
worth 12 billion dollars the NBA has a
TV deal worth twenty four billion over
nine years and each NFL regular season
game is worth nearly twenty four million
in revenue from TV rights alone so they
want their content and even though that
content is coming not enough of it is
coming and compensation just happens to
be paid money's been short all around a
lot of players have taken pay cuts but
as teams plan their comebacks the virus
hasn't gone away and there's still no
vaccine what about a situation like the
Premier League footballer Troy Daley we
do want return to training because of
the disproportionate effect that a
pandemic has had on the bank community
as a black man and a black athlete was
he more risk in the u.s. there trying
something new men's basketball the NBA
and soccer the MLS are going to be holed
up at Disney World in Florida teams will
live train and compete in a sealed-off
virus-free bubble obviously they would
have to be tested on their way and they
would have to get tested every day but
there will be a portion of time and it
could be as long as a month or so where
they would not be able to sweep their
wives and kids it's a lot of disruption
still it comes down to choice and that
goes for any future vaccine - you can't
assume that every single athlete from
how many different countries all around
the world I could be happy to assess the
vaccine that's been developed in you
know roughly a year but as countries
have started lifting their lockdowns
sports have said it's game on
[Music]
it was easy enough for rugby to resume
in New Zealand with full contact and
full stadiums they declared themselves
virus-free in June but other sports have
returned without their fats like Korea's
K League what pro baseball in Taiwan
[Music]
where teams played in front of cardboard
cutouts and robotic drummers cage in
time he'll enjoy overtime he didn't
coach yeah no they assume you're bound
by the Bundesliga is back to but the
empty stands are is weird for the
players as they are for the fans
oh no just a lot this is a recent study
suggests more than half of sports fans
say they won't feel comfortable in large
crowds for a while the big sports are
expected to find ways to survive but
it's the smaller sporting communities
the amateur and youth leagues that might
struggle Cubs will go out of business
people will lose their livelihoods
people won't get to play the sport that
they want or deserve to play because the
scheme that was in place is no longer in
place and what about women's sports with
money drying up there's not much to go
around
the top women's divisions in England
France and Spain have already been
cancelled
we're definitely seeing evidence around
the world of lease investment and
women's money is being redirected to the
recovery of means what you mean very
beautiful that will actually see it's
near additional loss I mean term that
we've heard there may be some positive
outcomes from all this to cut costs and
the risk of global travel some
tournaments might rethink their
schedules and that would be a good thing
for the planet there might even be
conversations about whether they're
paying superstar athletes too much money
already save games from Johnny and
fanciness favorite president that he
thinks things should change to talk
about salary caps there would have been
mutiny a few months ago sports are
expected to get back to normal
eventually and plenty of fans will tell
you they really needed to have these
teams back on the field on the court
will be good it'll do its force is
always done in the past is allow us for
a moment when the game is happening to
not think about the real world
real world concerns about the virus
though mean the comeback could be seen
as risky business for the athletes and
their fans but at the end of the day
sports is the business
and if anything the pandemic is exposed
of just how big of the business
it really is
[Music]
if there's a story or a topic in the
news that you find confusing and you
want us to explain get in touch with us
on Twitter or Facebook also make sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel so you
don't miss our next episode
[Music]